le président ukrainien vous le voyez se
couche devant les parlementaires
français en virtuel évidemment une
intervention vidéo que vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne dans quelques instants le
président caennais qui s'est exprimée
déjà ce matin devant le parlement du
japon virginie est est avec nous en
attendant que volodymyr zelensky
prennent la parole est-ce que vous avez
déjà une idée de la teneur de son
discours parce qu'on peut dire de ces
messages précédents adea des adc nawa
des assemblées parlementaires c'est que
en général il adapte son discours enfin
le discours est toujours le même il a
besoin d' aide il est seul et on défend
plus pour écouter volodymyr année le
chiffre qui prend l'apparence
pour la première fois de notre histoire
parlementaire
nous accueillons le président d'un pays
en guerre
d'un pays à la capitale a siégé
sur lesquelles les frappes redoublent
d'intensité en ce moment même
car l'inadmissible est en train de se
produire
la guerre en europe aux portes de
l'union européenne la guerre en ukraine
notre peuple monsieur le président
d'ukraine force l'admiration
alors qu'il est la cible d'une agression
que rien ne peut justifier
alors qu'il est la victime d'un appétit
de conquête territoriale qui fait voler
en éclats toutes les règles de la
communauté internationale alors qu'il
est la proie de la folie meurtrière des
autorités russes le peuple ukrainien se
bat
et l'ukraine un civil et militaire
résiste jusqu'à l'héroïsme pour défendre
la souveraineté de leur pays et leur
liberté
aux yeux de l'europe et du monde
je souhaiterais mes chers collègues
parlementaires avec les membres du
conseil de paris je salue et qui nous
écoute que nous nous levions et
applaudissions afin de rendre hommage au
courage du peuple ukrainien et de
vous-même monsieur le président
sa collègue
une âme et messieurs le temps n'est pas
seulement à l'émotion il est avant tout
à l'action
nous dirait dans un instant monsieur le
président de craine ce que vous attendez
de notre pays la france
permettez moi de vous remercier d'avoir
fait le choix en pleine tourmente de
vous adresser au parlement des grandes
démocraties et singulièrement au
parlement français pour transmettre le
témoignage de l'ukraine et de vos
attentes
ne doutez pas de notre soutien pour
aujourd'hui et pour l'avenir
votre respect de l'institution
parlementaire
distincte votre pays de ses adversaires
il fait sens dans son combat l'ukraine
défend aussi nos valeurs celles de la
démocratie de l'humanisme de la liberté
de la civilisation européenne
oui parce que l'ukraine appartient à la
famille européenne
je vais maintenant donner la parole aux
présidents ferrand qui va prendre la
fuite monsieur le président
monsieur le président de l'ukraine
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les députés sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
du corps diplomatique
c'est un honneur pour nous de vous
accueillir au sein de l'assemblée
nationale
nous connaissons votre attachement à la
france où vous avez effectué votre
premier déplacement officiel à
l'étranger
après votre élection comme président de
l'ukraine vous aviez ainsi engagé dès
2019 un dialogue fructueux avec la
france je tiens également à saluer la
présence parmi nous de l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine en france monsieur vadim
omeltchenko
oui
depuis maintenant près d'un mois de
guerre les ukrainiens se bat et résiste
de façon héroïque à l'agression
militaire russe soyez sûr monsieur le
président de la solidarité et de
l'entière mobilisation de la
représentation nationale nous
continuerons de veiller à ce que tout
soit mis en oeuvre pour vous porter
assistance qu'il s'agisse de l'adoption
de mesures restrictives à l'encontre de
l'agresseur de la fourniture d'un
soutien humanitaire aux ukrainiens comme
réfugiés nous avons tous vu ces images
choquantes bouleversante de villes
ukrainiennes bombardée et assiégée
la france condamne ces actes et ses
bombardements indiscriminés
visant les populations civiles cela doit
s'arrêter immédiatement et nous appelons
la russie à se conformer au droit
international humanitaire dans ces
circonstances tragiques
le peuple ukrainien fait preuve d'une
résistance admirable je tiens à saluer
son courage et séduit des autorités
ukrainiennes
sachez que nous demeurons à vos côtés
monsieur le président de l'ukraine vous
avez la parole
merci
merci c'est un grand honneur pour moi
pour le cren et pour notre peuple
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir eu
l'honneur de m'adresser à vous
aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que vous savez très bien ce
qui s'est passé en ukraine vous savez
pourquoi cela se produit et vous savez
qui est coupable
et même ce qui est ce cas qui cache la
tête dans le sable
et c'est de trouver de l'argent en
russie
et je m'adresse à vous aux gens honnêtes
rationnelle et audacieux
et je voudrais poser une question
comment arrêter cette guerre comment
instaurer la paix en ukraine parce que
la plupart des questions et des réponses
de son dans vos mains dans nos mains le
9 mars et les bombes aériennes russes
ont été
lancés sur le pétale pour les enfants et
une maternité dans notre ville de mario
paul c'était oublier les
paisibles dans le sud de l'ukraine
complètement paisible jusqu'à ce que les
troupes russes sont venus et l'ont pris
dans un siège brutal comme au moyen âge
et ils ont commencé à tuer les les gens
dans cette maternité
sur laquelle le russe ont lancé les
bombes il y avait des gens il y avait
des femmes qui se préparer à accoucher
et la plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessés
et une femme a dû amputer son pied qui a
été fracturée et une autre femme avait
en bassin fracturé et son bébé et mois
avant la naissance
la femme on essayait de sauver la femme
elles demandaient les médecins de
laisser mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle ne vais pas dire elle ne voyez pas
des raisons pour vivre
elle est morte en ukraine en europe en
2020 de
caen des centaines de millions de
personnes ne peuvent pas penser que le
monde pouvait être détruits
et je vous demande d'observer une minute
de silence à l'honneur à la mémoire des
milliers de l'ukrainien et d'ukraine yen
qui ont été tuées à la suite de
l'invasion russe du territoire ukrainien
lol merci
après les semaines novation russe marie
paule et d'autres villes ukrainiennes
frappé par l'occupant rappelle les
ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune
à vue a vu l'armée russe ne distingue
pas les objets qu'il cible ils
détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux les écoles les
universités tôt ils brûlent les
entrepôts de nourriture et de
médicaments
ils brûlent tout
il ne prend pas en compte les concepts
du crime de guerre
les causes obligations sur les
conventions et ils ont apporté la
terreur sur le cheikh lui cria et chacun
de vous un inconscient vous avez toutes
les informations d'autres disponibles
tous les faits sur les femmes violées
par les militaires russes dans les zones
temporairement occupés sur les réfugiés
qui qu'elle tue sur les routes sur les
journalistes qu'il tube sachant
exactement que ce sont des journalistes
sur les anciens qui ont survécu à
l'holocauste et sont maintenant obligés
de fuir dans les abris anti banques des
frappes russe
l'europe
n'a pas vu depuis 80
temps l'europe n'a pas vu ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine
il ya des gens désespérés qu'il supplie
de mourir
en 2019 quand je suis devenu président
il y avait déjà en format pour les
négociations avec la fédération de la
russie c'était un format normandie le
format d'une récession qui devrait
mettre fin à la guerre dans les zones
basses la guerre à l'est de l'ukraine
qui dure depuis huit ans malheureusement
et quatre états ont participé au format
normandie le cren la russie l'allemagne
et la france
4 mais il représentait tout le monde le
monde entier les positions du monde
entier toutes les positions quelqu'un
l'a soutenu et quelqu'un a essayé de
retarder le processus et ils voulaient
le perturber mais il semblait important
que le monde ait soit toujours à cette
table normandie
et donc il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité et
quand nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2019 c'était une bouffée
d'air frais comme une leur d'espoir
l'espoir que les conversations avec la
russie peuvent aider que les dirigeants
de la russie peuvent être persuadé par
les paroles de moscou de choisir la paix
mais le 24 février est venu le jour qui
a barré tous les efforts
et même le concept du mondial hoc
et la barre et l'expérience européenne
des relations avec la russie et les
destinées de l'histoire en europe tout
cela a été bombardée par les troupes
russes écrasé par l'artillerie russe et
brûlé après les tirs de missiles russes
on n'a pas trouvé de vérité dans les
bureaux
et on est obligé de chercher la vérité
sur le champ de bataille
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste nos
valeurs l'unité et la détermination de
défendre notre liberté
notre liberté commune pour paris et pour
kiev pour berlin et varsovie pour madrid
et rome pour recel et bratislav
les bouffées d'air frais ne nous
aideront pas
nous devons agir ensemble de faire la
pression ensemble pour faire la russie a
cherché la peine mesdames et messieurs
le peuple français le 24 février
le plus criant cti et aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus ni de représenter en 3d
représentant de gauche nous ne faisons
pas attention à ce qui est ce qui
représentait le pouvoir
et la coalition et l'opposition et on
pense de l'instauration de la paix
pour protéger notre pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à la france
que la france nous aide nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour les efforts du
président macron qui a fait preuve dans
véritable leadership nous communiquons
constamment avec lui nous coordonnons
nos pas et les ukrainiens on voit que la
france apprécie également la vérité et
vous les protégez
vous vous savez ce que c'est la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
et chaque parole est important pour vous
je le sens et les ukrainiens le récente
et nous attendons de la france de votre
leadership
que vous puissiez faire en sorte que la
russie cherche la paix m pour mettre fin
à cette guerre contre la liberté contre
l'égalité contre la fraternité contre
tout skieur rendu l'europe unie et
libre et diverses nous attendons de la
france de votre leadership la
restauration de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine on peut le faire ensemble
et s'il ya ceux qui ont des doutes entre
les personnes présentes alors je peux
vous dire que votre peuple est sûr comme
tous les autres peuples de l'europe
et pendant la présidence française de
l'union européenne
une décision
mûrie sur apprises sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne une
décision historique à un moment
historique
comme cela a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire du peuple français
mesdames et messieurs le peuple français
demain ce sera au mois que les
ukrainiens se battent pour leur lier
leur liberté que notre armée ce boss de
maeyer et de riz et or et ori héros rick
aux forces supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux dad encore plus
dette de plus de soutien pour que la
liberté ne tarde pas elle doit être bien
armé les chars les armes antichars les
avions de combat la défense et riant
vous pouvez nous aider nous en avons
besoin vous pouvez pour que la liberté
ne tarde pas le monde doit les soutenir
avec des sanctions contre l'agresseur
chaque semaine on ne vaut pas cas de
sanction
les entreprises françaises doivent
quitter les le marché russe renom auchan
leroy merlin et autres doivent cesser
d'être les sponsors de la machine de
guerre de la russie
les îles
ils doivent arrêter de financer le
meurtre d'enfants et de femmes le viol
tout le monde va se rappeler que les
valeurs
valent plus que les bénéfices
et nous devons déjà pensé de l'avenir de
la façon dont nous allons vivre à après
la guerre il faut des garanties et des
garanties sur que la sécurité sera
inébranlable et que les gars ne seront
plus possibles dans ce monde
nous créons ce système de garantie au
nouveau système de sécurité
où la france aura un rôle de premier
plan pour que personne
ne devrait jamais en pleurer la mort
pour que les gens vivent leur lit
et pour qu'on dise à dio pas sous les
bombes pas en état de guerre
mais quand leur vient
avec la dignité parce que nous devons
vivre pour être respectées
pour conter guise d'au revoir
comme les français a dit au revoir à
belmondo
merci l'apprend ce couloir a le crâne
[Applaudissements]